liebes tagebuch dann habe ich das neunte
türchen aufgemacht und es war schokolade
drin eine tasse mit dem santa clause
habe ich mir auch gegönnt da kommt jetzt
wasser ein
zumindest wiki geschrieben ich komme
aber kein englisch habe keine ahnung was
das bedeutet jedenfalls hab ich mir dann
die fingernägel lackiert ich bin leider
farbenblind etwas angezogen und hab dann
gedacht durch doch mal meine puppen dann
kommt der bruder der alte notgeile
trickste wollten auch die bubis kletten
javascript leck mich so dass ich
besoffen weil er sauer war ich hingegen
habe ein herr in tier gefressen
und was soll ich sagen eine rentier
schmeckt richtig lecker van bommel beim
revier auf der party reviews spaß
unterwegs fressen als gäb's kein morgen
mehr
der frodo hingegen war so sauer dass er
gedeckt und an seiner schleck stange
gelutscht hat zügig montag getanzt als
werder grad total auf drogen und dann
auch vor anderen leid von denen ich bis
heute nicht weiß wie sie heißen waren
auch mit dabei wir haben uns sinnlos
besaufen der da hinten ist völlig
ausgeflippt in weiß haben getanzt frodo
hat scheinbar mit diesen haider getextet
auf den steht also mich hat die besten
dance moves ausgepackt und dann haben
wir diesem annika schilling ausprobiert
geld bei super funktioniert bis achtung
dieser dreck step jetzt her schaut ja
von wegen versaut zu recht haben uns ein
stück gefilmt und abzocke noch einmal
und im nächsten jahr spürst du ja immer
nur nett oder frodo was hätte den sonst
so ein text in dem haider
das ist wieder so typisch hat er wird im
nächsten jahr auch noch schon ist ja
auch egal jedenfalls habe ich das
nächste türchen aufgemacht und es war
schon klar in meinem typische nutzung
ist meine katzen völlig aus clips ahnung
sagt am wasser mal obacht der tisch der
kerb mir und außerdem hätte ich gerne an
den schlaf mit deine schuhe jetzt wird
wahrscheinlich so sein dass man im
nächsten jahr
anwurf erwarten zwischen kurz und schuhe
also schon mal wird es so ausschaut wird
wahrscheinlich relativ breit auch die
haben an der stange genug wieder frodo
und habe das nächste wirtschaft macht
klatten wird es nicht glauben können und
weil seine blog gibt in der welt habe
angehalten mittlerweile so
zusammenbrüche von mir dass es in
rollstuhl setzen abmessen zwar natürlich
bloß spaß der rollstuhl werden
ist ein bruder dann sind wir mit 400 km
auto innenstadt gefahren auf verleiht
vom stern nutzen deswegen denn wir
wollten den gulden frodo frisur
verpassen er hat man das wenn extensions
wir haben uns natürlich auch dann doch
eher richtig die haare so weckwerth dass
er danach halt ausschaut wird der kanal
auf koks hingegen ob ein richtiges
haupthaar schützenswert natürlich schon
dunkel
ich bin viel zu langsam wieder foto
mittlerweile richtig am arsch sitz des
querkopfs mensch sage immer warum
hermann gero sieht und ihn mittlerweile
gewährt gefühlen die wirkungsorte wollte
eigentlich rosarote hhl de france hans
hartung rüstung von medarex cap gemini
find den als ehrten oder was das war mit
seinem 5 nur der flora frey zdf
neuwieder der love macht man wird es
nicht glauben es war klar jetzt muss ich
los angeles seit tagen für diesen shop
plattform ist leicht schlechter mir doch
wurscht hauptsache sie sagt so wie es
heute und dann noch in einen stepptanz
mit meiner neuen jacke die ich jemanden
aus der army geklaut habe doch wieder
fressen kurz vor mittlerweile schon so
fertig dass ganz aus und dann ist mir
das passiert was immer passiert ich
verfalle in ein mächtiges schokoladen
koma das heißt es mir dann förmlich im
auch die wildesten gering massen weiß
überhaupt nicht was normal ist wieder
schlaganfall machen was mit die finger
und penny in diesem sinne gute nacht
wenn ihr den haider nicht kennen was ich
gar nicht glauben kann dann hört euch
das mal an abonnieren den haider auch zu
abonnieren und sagt danke schön haider
und das kleine katze henry